All right, I'm going to give this a shot.
Let's start with number of critical resources. We've
got HTML, CSS, and JavaScript, so that seems
like there are three critical resources. Okay. Total
critical bytes. We've got 5 Kilobytes for HTML,
4 for CSS, and 2 for JavaScript, so
that's going to be 11 total Kilobytes. And
then minimum critical path length or round trips.
Let's see, hm. Is it going to be two or three?
Can the browser download both the CSS and JavaScript in parallel?
>> It's two. The browser can download both files in parallel. Note that
the number of critical resources and
the total number of Kilobytes has increased,
but the critical pathlength stayed the same. Now as an exercisem imagine that
each round trip took one full second because you're on a really slow connection.
How long do you think it would take for us to render something on the screen?
>> 2 round trips. 1 second each. 2 seconds or so.
>> Yep. Now, imagine you're on the latest,
super fast fiber connection, with 50 millisecond round-trip time.
>> Seriously, now you're asking what's 2 times
50 milliseconds. Yeah, it's going to be 100 milliseconds.
>> It's a good exercise. Now you have a good approximation
for how long the page will take to render. And it
only took a minimal amount of analysis.